[__] start of your rewarding old
readings from podcast Ville it's June
8th Monday you bad [__]
grab your [__] balls it's over
if you got time to protest you got time
to go back to work by the [__] it's over
you don't give a [__] you going back to
work now that's it nail salons full of
Pete everybody's going back to work it's
all over
kick this [__] mealy
[Music]
I'll poach over here and I'm one day
mourning smoking the same week Chris
Cuomo smoked when he got rid of the
[__] covert 19 this is the weed he
smoked they just don't tell you that you
don't see a bank does that [__]
anyway we're back [__] we're not
gonna talk about Bruce Lee today we're
gonna talk about Bruce Lee on Wednesday
I'm not gonna spoil it look you got two
[__] days to watch it okay if you
didn't watch it don't [__] listen on
Wednesday we'll cover him Bruce Lee so
I'm letting you know right now what time
is number one how are you [__] it
was a great weekend
I did not I want some money I want some
[__] money hey listen I know it's
been a rough week I haven't I've been
bored to death I was telling Lee how it
went down Lee was the one that told me
was a card I didn't know it was a
[__] card and I get any points on the
kiss of death you're [__] living
moisture so I'm I go I'm out of a ride
Lee goes he's watching the fight with
his father I go I'm nice I didn't know
the [__] fights Amanda knew Nate
forgot that's how we're my mind with
this [__] child this [__]
homeschool now there's no camp [__]
June 15 so it goes my [__] until July
a different [__] camp
I don't feel about putting Crenshaw at
this point I don't give a [__] speaking
of Crenshaw imitate what happened I see
this [__] fight right I would go on
the car and Lee tells me in the my other
buddy called you from Jersey they tell
me there's a parade in Hudson County
Park and he can't walk this dog so I
told my boys you ever seen a man there
walking your dog for put him in the yard
no I mean almost I read him off the card
and I see that Alex Cesare is fighting
the nice white kid the 20 year old look
like this and something made me just go
to the lines and look like I went to my
bookie I'm like 3:30 and I saw that he
was none the dog and I went I did
something with Mercia did someone my
wife I'm thinking about this whole thing
how can he be an underdog he's 31 years
old this white kid is a second fight I
looked at and then doing the Priya
during the prelims they said that
somebody had bet a million dollars on a
man the Nunez so I said there's no
[__] future and betting the main card
there's gonna be a some [__] salami
switch there something's gonna happen
trying to [__] you up do something so I
said let me stay away from that I feel
like gamblin so I said let me take the
underdog Alice cáceres number one if
you're black and you're an underdog I'm
bettin you this week I just think you
[__] there's no way if you're a white
dude and you're fighting a black dude
this week just going and go listening
he's cuz rights are connecting you saw
it last night
they're throwing heavy [__] rights in
they're connecting you don't want to
find out more African American the next
two weeks give him a breather go down
let him tepee and just go down because
they they're angry and I don't blame you
so rather whack I said this guy's gonna
be up this little white kid and sure
enough he [__] them up he won a
unanimous decision I want some money I
didn't even watch the card you know what
I ended up watching my cell by the way
my guest tonight is the beautiful mr.
Eric Rocha which we'll get to later he's
a young comedian because everybody every
on the podcast always says well you need
names what [__] names we're just
trying to make it funny and entertaining
to you people you don't need no names
names are gonna come in here and be fake
I want real Eric Roche is real so let me
tell you how he saved me but we'll get
to that [__] story later so I called
my buddy I go back on the clock computer
not my cab every night my computer goes
kaput from 5:30 to 7:00 cuz everybody's
on it oh okay so I can't get on my
boogie so I'm dying to get on my bookie
I can't get on my bookie my wife is
helping me something with the row row
row row rather router she was somewhat
to rather I'm like [__] [__] bet
this patch right this [__] Bruce Lee
Phooey whatever movie Roy from the Last
Dragon so I'm sitting there I go you
know what let me call my buddy cuz I
don't again I call go ahead you take UFC
action he goes nah but I got a friend of
this hill can you vouch of me without me
having a run across to town and give him
cash and he was yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
I'll pour you back coughing back because
what do you want a betting I want to
build a prelim fight because which one I
go how is Casares against the kid he was
I yeah so I just tune him out on it and
I knew he was an underdog always take
like I love on the dog's name Nick Diaz
[__] the San Francisco 49ers against
Dallas Cowboys 83 I love an underdog
because I'm an underdog
I always cheer for underdogs so I said
[__] I blast and then he told me listen
to me when you're gonna win some good
money so I watched the fight and then I
[__] won some money okay what am I
gonna watch the [__] bank guard I'm
gonna save you so be five hours I'm
saying let me take my money and go home
that's what you did you take your money
y'all there's no more [__] around
don't hanging out no doing nothing oh I
had a nice night but I didn't watch the
fights what I did was to prepare for
Bruce Lee on Sunday night I watched a
movie I taped this week and I want
everybody's your homework assignment for
next week I want you to learn something
I watched the movie called the getaway
with Steve McQueen and Ali MacGraw she's
one of the beautiful women you've ever
seen in your life as far as acting Jane
no [__] Natalie Portman
but she's so [__] good-looking that
she's phenomenal and when you look at
Steve McQueen and the getaway its listen
to this it's directed by Sam Peckinpah
and written by walk the hill the guy who
wrote warriors and all that this is just
insane and 48 hours right so last night
first of all when I switched from
[__] before I even went to Saturday
night before I even went to Steve
McQueen
I watched training places from the
beginning for nice oh my god oh my god
oh man I watched the whole [__] thing
and I realized that Eddie Murphy was a
[__] savage back in the day you know
he did one movie here that was his
second big [__] release in 83 and I
got tobu 83 is up just [__] they don't
even make movies that's a good movie for
black people that movie had so many
different [__] levels in it that movie
had so many dude okay everybody
everybody that's when he's falling in
love I go Terry they'd only make news
like that no more [__] but some man went
to [__] the getaway and I'm watching
the Queen and after I watch it to the
part that he beats his wife on the round
on the whatever he really beat the [__]
out of him you know if you watch it on
YouTube he beats it and it's just a
scene in the movie but he was like a
[__] real actor and he was a tough
guy he was one of Bruce Lee's disciples
he [__] carried Bruce Lee's
Caspian when they buried him him and a
bunch of hot but Steve McQueen was just
intense I read about him for years my
mother took Missy to get away like I was
crying last night because I remember my
mother take that's the shoes distantly
Cubans love Steve McQueen that
[__] was [__] slapping people
bullet Cubans love Steve McQueen
Cadillacs Cubans love all that [__] they
love Steve McQueen my mother took me for
the matinee we went to dad Steakhouse
got a steak with garlic bread and then
we went the [__] in the 42nd Street the
whole time she wouldn't shut the [__] up
about [__] Steve McQueen a beautiful
let the white man do his work as you
people it was such an all-star castle
I'm happy I wants to get away before
because now I'm prepared for what I'm
gonna get but I told you Wednesday's
Bruce Lee anyway Erich Roach is a very
nice young man I met him a year ago two
years ago when I was in a dark spot
before my Netflix special he really made
me laugh and I've always loved them he's
a young comic and you heard him I don't
[__] know and I don't [__] know I
know he's done the podcast I'm bringing
them into your living room how are you
Eric
I'm doing good last week you put a man
that killed me now I'm gonna explain
something I'm a [__] savage but I
never knew nothing sexually nothing like
when I was 32 I found out what a sugar
daddy was I never knew child was 32 I
should be ashamed of myself
that's how on whatever I did coke and
[__] that surprises me that you don't
yeah well as time went on I dated the
girl who took me to a different level
she wanted to be smacked I did it to
girls back to back one want to come on a
face so she could come I never heard of
that before
how did you even get conclusion what do
you have guys I stopped dating I had a
checkup that's the first time I have had
a change because how do you get that
it's like who invented the mushroom so
you went around picking up [__] eating
stuff delicious how do you know if that
means guys came all over you think you
find out that somebody and she was young
young so she put me over the top a
little bit freaky spies and then I dated
another girl who was out there dildos
smack me in the face choke me I was not
into that [__] at all
and I ended up starting to choke her and
you know and then she would say smack me
and I had a smack or she called me a
[__] and she started smacking me
relationship but our relationship went
into a weird place it was a horrible
relationship but lasted for years but
she was a sexual demon and she would do
like all that [__] like you know take a
dildo and put it in a [__] but last
week while she was sucking you taking on
the night you know I would tie her up
this is the girl that used to make me
tire up and then go to go on and koala
from the pay phone she was on the
answering machine and say dirty things
to I never discovered things like this I
never know nothing about this [__] I was
just a straight guy regular you know I
never wanted to come on your back I did
the first time I [__] the girl in the
ass I was 30 and I didn't like it
I didn't like it it was like a power
play like for years I wanted to [__]
someone in the ass finally somebody left
me and I was like I don't like this
she was Quigley she kept moving she
wasn't focused I don't like that I want
you to be focused they don't like it I
don't like it so I never really [__]
nobody in the ass I don't know no about
that world I moved on you know you
always want to [__] somebody in the ass
then once you'd be like you know what
the same for me a little bit but I can't
put it back in the mouth you know I want
that one if I put in your ass I'll be
able to pop it in your mouth afterward
hit you on the head like a [__] like
Def Leppard's drummer I'm talking you're
gonna be a good mother [__] this
strap on a pair we're having a good time
today enough with the covet enough with
the riot
not with this [__] it's back to
[__] comedy time [__]
uncensored [__] comedy so you know
I'm [__] 20 you got Jenna putting
pictures she self farts she sounds a
farce wife retweet of their farts as my
support yes
if you're gonna buy a fart you're a
[__] [__] but [__] I would sell you
ten dollars for my farts and put him in
a jar whatever she does videos are like
rubbing a [__] and farting it the same
I've seen so I've tweeted him I retweet
him for never got a little nice girl
from Boston who I love jamie-lynn chubby
she got pissed at me because I called it
chubby she's not really Geo
she's for real like I like the
fixer-upper you labor she's too much for
you like when she moves her hips like
this have you seen to do that now my
gyrate dog you just be you just forget
it
you just you'll start to [__] it's like
the [__] it's like the zipline
adventure it's just going to shock I
love those women I support those women
if you can Holly housewife if you're
gonna [__] put videos of yourself on
the internet sucking dick have you seen
Holly housewives content now actually
she some Lori hos she's [__] all
types of people she just goes to a bar
and I've been has a gangbang it's
discussed this crime but it's good for
some people from time to time no no
people only is the coronavirus No
so I'm thinking about the other day how
you know when I get on the computer and
I see it there's a picture that you
posted of you [__] up some guy from
behind choking them with a [__] and like
you know like that ice at them then you
put lee in the corner like whatever like
saying hello it was tremendous you know
that that made my day that's like a
personal [__] message to me going here
this is for you you know it's like an
homage I'm like look at this
[__] posting gay content on this
thing that nobody does nobody post cake
I don't see it very seldom do I see gays
interacting on there maybe I'm on a
difference but here yeah so I saw that
dick around the neck and I was blown
away I'm like I never thought of that
that would have been tremendous like
that's gotta be a 16 inch dick
you just take their neck but instead of
pulling their hair and pull them back
like you did to the arrow the pair is
when you pulled his hair back because
that was a tremendous story I'll never
forget that that's I I love gay people
only ones left they still having a good
time white America you got your [__]
fingers put up your [__] ass gay
people are just meeting each other
online the trustor you have to have the
trust like hi how you doing good what do
you want to shoot whom I want to [__]
you in the ass okay why are you 1313
Mockingbird Lane you go over there your
father and you go home that's the
Munsters address anyway one time we went
to go do the the Comedy Store open mic
neither of us got up and he I was like
I'm gonna do another like he's like I'll
see you later I'm gonna go he got laid
in between mics that's amazing so my
thing is we've been talking a lot about
changing and let's go from comedy here
to just one minute of South real I watch
it get in and you know I love you to
death I've always I've always been
fascinated by the girl gay LGBT
community I've always you know since
[__] [__] my world up you know they
always did cuz you look at them you like
what the [__] is going on everything you
know what love is the [__] I'll tell you
honestly the last time I was here I had
so many gay people come up to me a a
bunch of gay people transgender people
they [__] love you I love that and
that's not all [__] my god what the [__]
if you give them somebody says some
about you you have to look at where
they're coming from
you know I the guys that live down the
corner from me they were transgenders I
thought they were doing the cat so they
had me here I'm talking to a guy with a
wig and a mustache found everything we
hidden shame I catch him out there a
little Ricky's twisted the wig was
twisted and [__] can I give a [__] now
that's what people want to do you and
Jim Norton those are the two that they
brought up cuz especially like after I
was I did the first show here all even
at the shows when we would do the shows
it was cool because in the [__]
craziest places two people would line up
and they'd be like hey either
this I'd like to introduce you some
chick that I'd like to introduce my wife
or my cousin's gay and we brought him
here and he thought you were [__]
hilarious and that's that's that's what
it is though that's what we wanted about
that's what we talked about I
and loved it so yeah that's your
question everybody's making changes the
other day I was on the [__] cashes
Morris show when I told me I was doing
online looking at courses to become a
[__] paralegal you know everybody
wants to make a change yes
everybody has looked into abyss
everybody's had a time to change
everybody's had a time to look at their
life and reexamine where the [__]
they're from that you know this is never
gonna happen to me again I lost a lot of
money I had to move back with my mother
I'm in a shelter people went through a
lot there but I was also thinking about
something I'm thinking about all the men
and women that realized during this
break that they maybe they were gay
think about that how many guys are at
home going you know what I'm looking at
my wife and I don't really [__] lie
for anymore but for some reason I have
to watch that Lance Armstrong get the
bike
I like the [__] guy in the ass like
Lance Armstrong or a woman saying you
know what man I'm sick and tired of
being around men I think I wanna switch
governments with whatever yeah it's a
lot of time by yourself a lot of time by
yourself what do you recommend like I
don't know how to come out but we joke
everybody makes jokes how does somebody
I've always thought about this like I've
always wanted to ask people why didn't
you come on it's gotta be painful and
exhilarating at the same [__] time
it's oh [__] that's uh that's a tough
one too
I knew like you know when you're a kid
you know you because there's something
different everybody starts talking about
[__] everybody starts talking about oh
you know I finger bang so-and-so I
finger bang someone so and for me I
remember it was like I I'm not [__]
interested in that and the shitty thing
was was it was like you start looking at
other people you're like I'm actually
more [__] attracted to that and
immediately you're like okay there's
something up like remember we're talking
about the whole [__] Catholic thing
so you've got that at odds with yourself
and you're like [__] okay I can't I
can't act on this [__] but meanwhile
they're having orgies in the basement
after [__] 7 a.m.
with three little with other kids you
know we gotta feel guilty but meanwhile
in between sessions of church that
downstairs with Capeside going holy war
they're little kids with a beach it's an
orgy somebody dropped them off they
don't know nothing you know what can you
I went through that guilt to one day I
was like these [__] put me
through hell for years for cursing
whatever I said when I found out those
[__] little kids like when I left the
Catholic I found out when I was like 15
I heard murmurs about Catholicism and
then when I was like 19 I was about the
Boy Scouts I heard a kid about like that
had been like molested and they put it
onto the table when I was 19 18 and I
heard about a 12 year old kid in our
area not a North Bergen that had been
because I was part of a Boy Scout troop
and they were kind of weird the first
day I went in there I preferred they
went right to nuts like the second day
they went right but not so I'm like it's
not me right here I'm gonna tell you why
else I called you in here today you know
what I ordered this week you know when i
pre-ordered rob halford steelbook he's
got a notebook the singer from Judas
Priest oh that was my first experience
like when I went to see Judas Priest I
was like rob halford could be a flame oh
boy we have a problem and I mean we're
going home and going so what so what
he's he's gay cuz they had this
motorcycle he came out with a motorcycle
on leather chaps and when I first saw my
I'll bet Flymo [__] broke brought a
whip out in October November 29th of 79
I saw them and that [__] brought
it with us at the Palladium in New York
City so you better [__] check
yourself so when he first came out then
when I first went to see them you know
he didn't come out till years later but
that made me think about you like who
all be like even rob outfit that was the
world when the world's greatest heavy
metal band is this guy walking around
and when you went to see it if you were
cool you knew it if you had experience
with a game in which I did I had I grew
up around Martin the [__] my dear Motty
cool so there was a game on my bar my
mother had gay guys around it you know
they did drugs I used to have gay guys
around me at the bar so like what are
you saying like right now after this
period how many people you think will
say you know what I always want to be
[__]
it's it makes a point because a lot of
time by yourself you you just you start
amen is especially like - with with
[__] divorces and [__] like that -
because you're starting to be around
your spouse and you just wonder I
[__] hate this [__] what am I doing
here
I tell you man I heard about this
in the beginning of the pandemic I heard
about that
be careful mental health you're gonna be
around and I'm not gonna tell you that
me and my wife had a few disagreements
we had a few times where you're at wit's
end and I said some or she'd say
something you know if Coronas on and
you're watching TV and your [__] skin
also she would say pass the remote what
do you think right and I you catch
yourself yeah but I caught myself early
like March like 20 around there I said I
have to get to come together with my
wife
I can't separate I gotta come together
and I'll tell you man it's been blessed
yeah we're going on 20 years July 1st
yeah I go this can't happen now this
cannot happen now we gotta at least make
20 years as you want look but she wants
to dump me on the second I'm doing it
but let me make it to the first one we
already [__] yeah well [__] you know
days away from 20 years of meaning so I
really really was constant about it I
avoided her at times I gave her space
there was nights you know little by
little like the firt when Lee told me
that he wasn't going to eat out that's
it I was like please nothing like I'm
standing in solidarity
right cuz this [__] you know I
never really go like they give it to him
lizard taco what do you think with what
was the first thing you did did you tell
your parents did you go to your priest
did you knock a friend could you just
bang a guy yeah that's essentially you
know you know what it was was it was um
I I'd met the guy and I still do jokes
to this day I'll call my my ex it was my
first ex boyfriend and we live together
in all that [__] and I remember he we
met in college and you know he was
flirting with me and for the first time
ever you pursue it first time ever
because I was in New York I was away
from home nobody [__] knew what I was
doing that's that's usually why like
when you look at where behavior like
that comes from they [__] go like
remember the rambles was famous in New
York in Central Park because gay guys
would go there at night and they would
[__] around with other guys Jesus Christ
I just forgot all about the rim there
you go see that's where that guy got mad
at that girl recently right I'm watching
I don't know okay never mind
it doesn't matter so but the thing of it
though is is whatever leads your your
limitations and says you know what try
it try it cuz yeah it is exhilarating
like when you first come out you [__]
tell everybody you're like I I'm gay I'm
gay I'm gay and everyone's like II okay
like today it's like who gives a [__]
but when you first start coming out you
I think you do it in small steps
cuz you come out to your friends people
that you're you're really really really
[__] close to and honestly what I
find a lot of people say is oh I knew oh
I knew I talked to a high school teacher
and he's like hey III heard you been
doing all this [__] that's good stuff by
the way I knew you were gay in high
school I was like how the [__] did you
know how did you I hid that [__] really
[__] well apparently I didn't cuz a
[__] ton of people look oh we knew and
it's like god damn so it's I don't even
know how you would go about it because
it's such a personal thing that
you can't rush it cuz you'll you'll [__]
somebody up if you out them like they'll
you've seen the goth kids they get
[__] let's [__] them sir it's not
exactly the same but all I can think
about is like Joe you went through a
period where you didn't tell people your
criminal stories and then like you
slowly started telling people maybe
maybe that's it because I will tell you
it is it's terrifying like in I remember
I was [__] around with somebody in
high school and somebody had seen and I
was ready to kill that [__] had
they ever spoken up but it was like that
scary where it's just like okay nobody
can find out about this [__] nobody and
then over time it's it's honestly it's
people like like you like like I said
Jim Norton you talk about other people
all these all these things you start
seeing gay people on TV and my problem
was was the gays that I saw on TV
weren't like me and that bothered me
because it's like well I'm not [__]
like that whoa hey not to interrupt you
but I've noticed one thing to see I've
noticed it with everything listen well a
lot of people don't know about me as I
paid an investigator a lot of money to
find my daughter find a few friends that
had apologized to and the one person
that I paid this investigator to look
for was a whenever I need his name I
forget it was an african-american kid it
was my first friend he was my first
friend in New York City took me to his
house his family took me and you know it
was Jasper Jasper Williams it was like
two years of just and then they made it
you know it's probably got a better job
and in went away you know they moved up
to Brooklyn and we lost contact whatever
I was exposed to gay people at the same
age hmm I didn't know what to think
about it and then as I went to my
mother's bar men would say so people
money go and I would go what the [__] is
a mighty throne and they would
tell me you know cuz my mom would go
knock it off he's [__] six you know
knock it off when you tell me the guy's
a [__] boy he ain't even gonna understand
it but by the time I was like seven or
eight I got it I got it I got I got the
behavior I didn't understand the Cecil I
lived in the house that was very
Santeria bound Santeria is [__]
glittered with gay men really yes but in
Cuba there was a form of a religion and
those guys the Abba croisé they're not
allowed in a room if there's a gay man
in that room the freaking Romero told me
when he was on Jose with me I asked him
if I'm a quest still exist it was a
brotherhood of men but now there's some
gay guys in there they finally opened up
about a minute in Cuba this was like a
religion of yeah if you [__] with me
I'll slice your ass you know that's why
they slice your ass because the hatred
they had for gay men oh yeah you know
Cuba don't ever think the cuboid people
said oh my god
Havana was moving yeah in a neighborhood
the neighborhood when she went on that
neighborhood they didn't like gay people
and they really liked black people if
you took them me United States his
racist I was braum dyeing my uncle's
just too [__] old to get him up here
me my uncle talked at night and he from
last week he's been telling me raise his
stories from Cuba every night how they
[__] they hardcore [__] cuz he's
dark-skinned they made a cow kid make
his dog pissed on his back and he didn't
even know he was sitting watching a
baseball game and some kid came over and
made a dog piss on his back and he goes
that's the best thing happen to me
my life changed after that because you
don't know ever since that dog pissed on
my back on my luck changed he goes I'm
where I am today cuz that dog pissing on
that back even though they thought I was
[__] back cuz he's war Manning my
mother brothers but he's darker skinned
with the little hair whatever but anyway
to get away from that stuff it was
really weird like I never had a chance
to really have an opinion
about I knew in my world I had they were
cool now when I got to be 1413 you're
out in New Jersey and now I can't I'm
trying to fit in I'm the [__] [__] on
the neighborhood I'm trying to fit in
and these guys are using [__] like you
know and in the 70s when people found
out your [__] they will hunt you down
though you know gay people have not had
it easy in this country they will hunt
you down
what do you don't and they be up and you
know pull your hair and do all that [__]
so it wasn't easy me meaning Martin made
my life a lot easier and then when my
friends found out let me tell you how
weird it life is that my friends all had
a problem with Martin the fact but the
coke assault like a coke then I'll
[__] make you [__] give you
twitches in your neck and [__] job that
girl keiko in 1980 that guy was selling
must called that was [__] heavy-duty
boy so when I told him you know that gay
guy you don't like that's what gaming is
coke it's like you know it's the same
thing with ready with basketball we hate
black people but we love Kobe Bryant oh
okay so it's a you love Kobe because the
way he plays but it's the same thing so
and I did the same thing cuz I was
caught up and so in front of my friends
at a a gay people mm-hmm but in my heart
I had no agent for gay people yeah but
then when they found out the coke was
electrifying
there were like all the [__] go call him
up and then I had another gay guy who
sold me coke later on and they loved him
his name was Moody and his coke was so
good you bought I hate walking on a
Friday you didn't get home until Moody
that was his slogan his coke is so good
you buying a bond Friday you don't get
home till mundi oh my god
I didn't know drug doesn't slow good
yeah I don't know do you know any older
gay people Eric again yeah do you think
the generational thing cuz maybe back
then
Joe you're calling you that gay people
in the 70s would listen now we have I
could like I fell in love with Eric
because Eric wasn't flaunting their
sexuality i feet look at the guy for the
pecan restore a dear friend of mine Jeff
the piano player right
I could tell Jay Jeff is gates this day
one that I met him you know what I love
about Jeff he doesn't want to tell me
he doesn't sell it to me he doesn't that
creepy around me there's some gay men in
West Hollywood I mean one time I was
eating at the Brazilian place across
from one it's not there no more The
Laugh Factory used to have a Brazilian
place the Gaucho grill or something like
that oh [__] delicious and I was
sitting on a table and there was a guy
behind me I've said this I was like
nobody could be this guy I keep it over
the top like I could tell the guy was
just lonely he moved to Hollywood he
went to an audition 20 auditions he
didn't book nothing and somebody told
him you want a book stuff you gotta be
gay one night he went home and practiced
his war and he got tired of t-shirts and
he started doing situps to get the ABS
you could bro and in this town tell me
those guys don't exist look at the chick
that was dating [__] in Donnie Brasco
she was okay now she got kids and
whatever she don't shoot no more movies
what you think she stopped eating [__]
there was no movies that was done she
was gay when she came on said she was
gay she's working all the [__] time so
I know for a fact that in my heart and I
don't know people listen to me going Joe
how can you think me that cynical
I'm telling you when it comes to
Hollywood anything is possible people
will do anything they will sell their
souls so if it is being gay and of being
gay I just saw a show mom is it mom
there was an a a group and the guy was
gay I know that dude because he was a
deucer on the mezzos I think I did a
gangster movie where I play a gay guy me
and my brother a gay and then [__] it
was like grasped by the gay community
and the two got Michael or Pinot is his
name I won the way he is there anybody
knows Michael or Pinot last time he
worked he was working at IKEA as a
director for this you wish you had this
job nine to five directing videos on how
to put [__] together he had hit the
jackpot six five nine to five Clarkin
that's a different type of director no
weekend's no 12-hour days he was like
[__] this [__] but because of him I've
met a lot of we got to the gate Film
Festival yeah and all that stuff and I
went to the [__] movie that I'm
talking about this is 2001 guys but like
I it was it was a great experience for
me whatever but in Hollywood people
that's what that's why I think I fell in
love with you because I could just read
you you didn't flaunt it
you didn't then I saw you on stage tell
the joke about the [__] Arab and the
punchline to that joke is what it's
really brilliant about you that you said
you want the launcher you gave friends a
day later they were like you know you're
opposing urban outfitter did you see
them get [__] loser last week I was
taking a baby Jack I was how many gay
men were home crying oh my god not to go
online
[Laughter]
the CIA op dressed up is [__] those
the CIA operatives don't get me started
but that's the brilliance of that joke
that they were they said to you I should
boycott whenever how fit is or whatever
and you said boycott you think I'm
worried about a boycott I broke racial
barriers religious barriers I'm a
Catholic and I [__] the [__] Isis
and when the [__] Isis been in the
middle all this if you're gonna bomb the
United States this is the time the time
at this time if somebody's idea that
Isis wanted for the [__] DC it blew
themselves up you're like this is
perfect ending to the story just see a
bunch of white people running down the
street cuz Isis little some guy with a
pin just I do la do la pull the pin out
waiting for that all [__] week one
[__] Isis now I wanna know what the
[__] runnin Isis does this slippin if
you're gonna hit this is the time now
[__] country right now if I was Isis
we're doing that by yourself it's
alright and hummus dropping hummus bombs
from planes dropping them everywhere all
over Texas you know how people are
finding rocks I'd be finding hummus
everywhere they be canisters of hummus
on every block on the corner people as
all these numbers is coming from who the
[__] is running Isis you fail I've been
thinking about this all week
what a [__] Isis all this is a scan
of Kovac you know what the code came out
I just told them listen if you're out
there I just lost strength they were
static over there done if you're a
gangster you can't be scared of carpet
how interesting is that this is very
interesting this is a fact I found out
I'm a dear friend of mine a cop by the
way that last week they looted they said
they were losing with a higher area and
high-income area
I heard the reason why I didn't go to
Compton and all those neighborhoods in
East LA because those [__] said
listen we went to listen 92 we're not
[__] around you come into our
neighborhoods we will blast [__]
protesters that's what I heard bro I
heard anybody come into our name but I
heard the Mexican
so next time you're in the media telling
you that these protesters didn't want to
protest low-end or they haven't no it's
at the low end people the cops told me
this the cop friend of mine told me that
they didn't go down there because the
Mexicans and all the black people - said
African Americans said don't even think
I love that we won't shoot your [__]
brains out
I love that so that's what really
happens so see how everything is kind of
different money way back to something
since so how do you recommend somebody
come out do you go see a psychiatrist or
no I don't I don't know about you know
have you had gay friends that to come
out they went and spoke to a psychotic
another thing is you you've got a you've
got to seek it out in a way the nice
thing about today is it it's it's not
like the 1970s where I mean I have older
gay friends and those people of any base
office in the price of the yes those
guys have my respect more than any
[__] today because those guys
went through some [__] now here's a
different [__] those [__]
stated in during the covert thing but
the 8485 gay guys the ones that battle
days in the beginning they were out Oh
[__] day like [__] we [__] aids up
Kover they doing [__] to me hah spitting
go Birds face I always [__] met up
the ass when it was going around like
[__] joints Areva and you think I was
gonna carve it when I wear a mask we're
not doing nothing what sucking dick then
this whole thing is over sperm cures the
[__] cold victory you shoot some
sperm dying and throw two kills go but
it's proven see I'm gonna gay men got
covered over this zero zero HIV men
didn't attract this HIV men were like 2%
look up the [__] snacks I swear to
God
hope it is scared a [__] game man no
no my gay men don't give a [__] about
coping is not coming your mouth and
that's
firm just kills like Ovid right in the
windpipe you know why about this he
called me he called me one day it was
late and I didn't look I had a messages
from Joey and I go what the [__] and I
play it and it's late at night you're
doing a dog Liberace was a bad
[__] he was my life once I watch
that movie and see how he was creeping
up on young boys II [__] I make him do
plastic surgery to look like he started
looking into it I wicked that
[__] I went down a Liberace
foxhole one night oh my god he did that
to one you do it he was just [__]
[__] Steve every made of a driver he
made him do plastic surgery that's
mental abuse clean the pool all that
[__] mental abuse he had George oh how
much plastic surgery Liberace should
have been thrown behind bars next to
Harvey Weinstein in the gay community if
he was alive they charge him with clubs
again oh he fought rustling I love it
heard so many people he [__] people up
he was catching those young boys in the
seventies they were coming out here to
go to Holly I want to be on Melrose come
here I'll show you next thing you know
you [__] out his house rub his toes
they can see yourself where the [__] is
my life gun putting this wig on wig you
got a wig I can't imagine a guy with a
wig [__] maniac that's that's one of
my biggest [__] fees
I would have to turn around and
bitch-slapping now if I [__] the guy
with a wig I would come on his way I
would pick up I would pick up his wig
come on his bald head and put the wig
back you know I got big balls it'd be
like an Oreo cookie with extra [__]
white [__] that wig would move for years
it'd be hurricane tested even under
water come on oh my god this is what we
need ladies and gentlemen America enough
with the [__] who cares with Donnie
Wahlberg did 36 years ago you need
laughter in your life and I was here
today cuz I'm dying inside for the last
month everybody's scared that's it it's
all over now let me ask you a question
here okay tell you my favorite [__]
gay seventies guy was do you remember
Paul Lynde yes oh do you know who Paul
II was on Three's Company yes
do you remember Charlotte's Web he was
the little gay rat hey hey Charlotte you
got any garden that my agent before The
Longest Yard was a badass gay guy I mean
I love the death I haven't seen him he
went to Germany he was really really at
the agency and then he went to Germany
and he got sick okay
and he went to Germany then he came back
and I bumped into him Emory T one day at
the coffee shop and we hugged you know I
mean he was a little mad at me because I
left him cuz that like six agents before
I got the long as your will call me back
for the first offer got it everybody
else got hung up on hey you owe me ten
percent [__] you like you ain't get
nothing I told you
I totally get the work at Ted I like
three ages so they all went out variety
and saw the write-up so they started
calling me hey you got the longest shot
how do I get my commission I know you
get dick you didn't close like told you
every [__] day I'm the one that sent
the tape in he was one of those guys can
he got really upset with me so I told
him you gotta go [__] yourself that's
why I told you to be at that office at
10:00 you didn't go to the office at
10:00 they call me ended up it was the
weirdest thing the people who submitted
me for Longest Yard like they submitted
me and they never heard back and then
the longest Shard called the distant
friend of mine that's a public relations
chick and said you know how we get all
the Joey Diaz like after my loss serious
please nobody really got to the nobody
photo buddy got her ended up all in her
and then I went in and I booked the part
yeah and then I gave jka the commission
but that commission could have gone to a
guy named Fred or these big people were
still calling you about commissions even
though they didn't know because Fred
Toby
Fred told me that they wanted a stop so
you didn't fight for me you didn't go
around the back way and go this guy's a
comic so I had to figure out that yeah
I'm not a star but I'm going up against
two guys on hiring comedians and Adam
Sandler's a comedian so let me give I
don't give a [__] what they want to see
let me go submit it myself
but anyway back to that gay dude there's
a [__] mad about the longer shirt how
the [__] could we get on that that's why
he'd do everything Paul Lynde
you need to look up who Paul and he is
[__] hilarious
he would he would say the gays [__] like
and he no but like he wasn't out right
um I don't think so I think if you knew
that world you know who's gay yeah just
like regular [__] housewife he would
he would answer like Hollywood Squares
he would say oh god what am I gonna tell
him now he was creepy you get out he was
slinging dick up here
1970 he want to come back to my place
you could just hear it in his voice oh
they put him on everything but I didn't
take that I don't think that in the
seventies they they even looked at it
that way no well you hit it you really
hit it even Little Richard like that was
my favorite [__] gay guy when you
look back of people that like now he
pissed me off cuz he renounced that he
was ever gay and it's like okay
[__] whatever like if that's
really how you feel and that's fine it's
it's you know to each their own but he
would the [__] that Richard would do was
[__] brilliant just even though I know
that I'm good honey shut up and
everybody 60mm for you to say you were
gay and black Jesus Christ yeah that's
like saying you got Cobra tentative your
thing let me let me give you an elbow
going your way I will see you again you
like Bali in [__] the Godfather you
think I got a CFL ball you got gonna see
him no boy you know it's like being gay
and black at the same time in 1960 you
know watch the green book yeah
when they caught him in the [__] so do
you remember they do they didn't want to
undo the cuffs they just wanted to leave
him there shaming that was it must have
been see that's why that's why I loved
Little Richard though is because he was
[__] Flambeau and people stole his
[__] all the time they oh they always
used to say that rock and roll stole
from those guys from Chuck Berry from
Little Richard did all that [__] that's
that's why it disappointed me but I
understood it like I I get you know the
guys in that his autobiography at the
end he renounced well he's George
towards the end he just said you know I
I renounce that lifestyle and and you
know he found his way back to church and
he was older and I get it but you know
it doesn't make a little gay kid or a
little lesbian girl say oh okay that's
that's my champion but you know that's
the problem is these questions are so
complex
everybody wants a solid answer and it's
just like no like listen you know my
Maya my family my great-grandma probably
wouldn't have been okay with me being
gay you know and that's that's of it but
she was amazing to my mother
does that mean that I renounce her
completely and it's like no if you
really want to have a [__]
conversation you've got to have that
conversation people gotta understand all
aspects of it the only friends I have
have gay sons somebody that's tough your
friends have from Jersey they have gay
sons I got two friends I grew up with
that have caissons and they've told me
right out they've told me like a lunch
and I'm ready to laugh because I grew up
with this guy and I remember them being
13 saying [__] gay people and now you
know we all pay for our sins and now
you're putting up your son's game so
weird how I see the pictures of him with
his son and he loves his son you know
but I have two dear friends that they
have a gay son I
we've had great conversations I never
you know they told me about them and
it's weird when they're talking to me
about their sons and I appreciate it
that they're not they're proud at one
point listen you want to be proud and
that's that's what it is and that's why
it's such a complex thing it's but
shouldn't should you're gay should your
friends be tried for a [__] that they
said before they had the gay kid that's
that's why I'm saying is you know what
you has a difficult time 13 years ago i
watch exactly i watch delirious and i
still [__] laugh at Eddie Murphy's
mr. t that is [__] hilarious
then again though you know I came out of
[__] Blazing Saddles when they showed
it at a it was at an arc light right I
came out and I still love that [__]
movie and they were like this this is
it's it's terrible it's terrible
well it is so blatantly racist and I was
like did you pay attention to that movie
though because every white person in
Blazing Saddles is just about a [__]
idiot every single
remember Johnson Howard Johnson is right
about Fred Johnson they're all related
cuz they're all [__] each other
everybody of that time Bill Johnson is
right about Howard Johnson about Ted and
that you realize and then the cattle
stampedes right through all of them
we've had women stampeded and cattle
raped you know it's just I love that
[__] I think that you know it's like
when they it's like when they made vito
gaya be Sopranos you know and his his
gangster that you see him on a bar now
and in custom he wasn't the first gay
gangster oh [__] yeah he wasn't the
first gay one they've had like five of
them less and then well-known I take
Greg gay I grew up with a guy that was a
trend across dresser and everybody knew
it there was nobody's business would
evade that there were weeks at night you
know Apple six everything was fine you
don't know we we made a point not to see
it we overlooked it with love hmm we
overlooked it with love I had so much
love for the dude that you know what at
this point we're gonna be a crossdresser
and I just heard about it hang on be mad
at you you know I'm saying don't be
coming over my house I said you rose
expecting any love cuz I can't save you
I got six gorillas out of my couch
you're walking over with a twisted wig I
can't help ya I'll try I've got a
ball-peen hammer I'll try to help you
it's 1970 you know I've never seen
Crooklyn oh [__] yeah that's what I grew
up really looking when you won the
bodega and there's a Puerto Rican
transvestite and he's [__] tell him
the kid let me give the kids like what
the [__] is going on
that was the breaker in every Latino
neighborhood in the 70s there was one
crossdresser you know and and and
sometimes he caught a beatin sometimes
he was somebody's brothers so they gave
like a past yeah don't stand on this
neighborhood brother go over there you
know I just don't sell this corner
exactly so weird were the things I saw
and my reaction and watch like people's
expert like I want you to tell me
something today
I want you to tell me ten dirty secrets
that straight men don't know about gay
guys okay well first I gotta say this
though because in terms of helping cuz I
do I want to just say something I don't
wanna I don't want people listening or
looking Joey recruitin [__] trial is
he getting 10% maybe I don't know yeah I
haven't decided what deal with Wes Holly
what I'm gonna do but I don't want them
to go to what I want them three Valley
gay men a little bit more dignity Lewis
industry a little less amazing suck that
[__] pipe Harry you got it buddy did
I'm saying who you got tonight the LA
[__] King [__] no I got the [__]
that's that's a difference that is
different you you had a never ever and
this is this is the good thing though
and and you know if you're coming up and
you are gay you've got to understand
this too comedy breaks so many [__]
barriers really get that because like
one one thing I always loved about you
and I will say this to you leave the
virzi trip it's in Luke Allen Mike my
comic friends like my family never been
afraid to make a gay joke when I like if
I'm dancing either one of my comic
buddies I can just mention they'll say
check out [__] veto and The Sopranos
and I'll stop dancing of it but it's
always given [__] though it's always
given [__] and we just but that's the
thing like could you ever have a dude
that just was like dabbling like he
wasn't sure like you know okay I did it
one time and you were like I'm gonna
take him I had gonna [__] this
[__]
I'm let's take 300 milligrams I'm going
it's either of this what's it what's
this it's either reno a bust
I want this guy to tap out and go home
and say you know what I tried that gate
thing it wasn't a thumbs up a hospital
you know [__] it could you [__] them
sideways
like ident you [__] them towards the
right you hit deliver it's like a little
kick it's like John Jones kicking in a
little you gotta [__] up you ever [__]
something you hit him like you're
banging them from both directions like a
woman you never do that leak I never
[__] you can't reach the liver but if
you [__] the man he asked and you got a
12-inch [__] event you like a magician
that was gonna hit the give me something
get kicked the liver they just go down
he's held up by a dick oh my god oh my
god that's the [__] I wanna hear like
you [__] somebody that they called you
up like a week later so listen but I'm
changing my number cuz that was a
horrible experience my intestines hurt
I'm still score every time I shed a
little bit of blood comes out I was like
three garlic pills I want to fart here
to put some gay incense the garlic pills
backfire
I thought kombucha garlic pills which
set this room on fire but it actually
failed on a Monday I totally [__] for
garlic pills tonight a protein powder in
a bottle of kombucha and then just one
day three garlic pills with scrambled
eggs and I [__] I totally I go I'm
gonna fight so much I'm gonna drive very
crazy if that smell of raw [__] I'm
just gonna walk on and just rape you to
death you just jump on top rate believe
me come back Monday he's hanging he hit
the thing the Roberto Clemente place is
that the door is open
please crying in the corner what
happened I believe what happened I can't
tell you he's handcuffed like that guy
see he's already thought about [__]
me you see I'm saying it's predetermined
it's like three with that do it up and
[__] I got gifts for you guys I gotta
show you this this is your okay Joey
this is your pride fan thank you so if
it's ever hot oh my god and offense
right here okay now my [__] Lee this is
your pride fan it's a little different
thank you
alright check out Lee's oh my god you
don't have been thinking about you a lot
but the other night I really thought you
know I've watched some great movies just
great Matteo a movie I wish I was gay I
work this fan you know they work those
little knives let's go Chinese people
[Laughter]
shout out to the LGBT community brother
we love you [__] I love what
you're doing I dog the thing that herded
me the most on his whole corona is that
they cancel gay pride there's only
people they [__] up gay probably [__]
those dirty people down and the what's
those dirty people I get together
walking man and I solve it and burning
man that's HIV man that's a basically
get a bit a chat meet Kelvin and foot
fungus that's all you get is a Monday
podcast ladies and gentlemen we're
trying to [__] break them out here we
said some things that were off-color but
who give us a [__]
what would you rather sit there worried
about dying or you know on
laughing a little bit this is what it's
all about in a Monday [__] morning
and we provided it today you're gonna
say an Eric man give me one thing that
white guys don't know or any men know
that they would make him interest like I
always like that [__] about choking a
[__] with a dick was tremendous
I never put a ball on the girl's mouth
that would be tremendous the one thing
that might freaking the [__] out fisting
is making a comeback oh my god this is
it this is eight weeks of oppression
subjects I just wanna do a podcast that
was fun on a Monday whether you agree or
not whether we recruit young gay men
[__] everybody's recruited Scientology
gay community when the [__] is the
leader of Isis I got a bomb somebody
Isis I mean they're wide open and like
people like he did this for the podcast
Eric and I drove to San Diego once and
he was it was just quiet for a second I
look over he's watching gay porn on his
phone trying to follow you trying to
make you look see that's how they get
you
black beans I forget for a minute that
he's gay
the game [__] he's on the phone with
his mom and I'm sure I go what do you
think what do you think of it oh my god
the guy the [__] what is he doing is
he dying inside honestly I'll be i-i've
never went full fist no it's easy Jesus
this is what I've done I put my hand in
there as well and don't like these
things you just open up your hand with
like three fingers in there ass a little
bit it's called the Wii Wow yeah that's
tremendous I can't imagine fist and
somebody ask this just they're gonna
press charge is they gonna come back
honey
somewhere along the line they gotta come
back you can't stick a fist up my ass
that's not right that's that's inhumane
that's that's Roman Empire type [__]
that's daddy I love you guys for having
a sense of humor
Erik thank you very much for that I love
you man for having me always be my
friend thank you for sending me personal
message thank you for putting leading it
tweets man it's good to just [__] get
some laughs I love the [__] out of both
you guys just to see you again though it
was great to see you too I was thinking
you know people like all you need names
on the pile you just need to have fun on
your podcast and weed aren't fun what's
the point of this whole funk exactly I
want you [__] mr. no I they
rescheduled my brave dates for the 25th
to the 27th guys it's pretty since it's
only 200 show it's pretty much already
sold out they gotta move people from
Saturday to Thursday and Friday night so
I don't know what the ticket situation
is you have to call your brain improv
and find that but uh that's all I got
for you right now which is Brad June
25th to 27th and then I'm gonna start
doing it out there I think the third
Tuesday of every month or something I'll
keep you guys posted on dates
this is it just because all this [__]
will back to work don't mean don't take
nothing for granted brother we don't
know nothing yet keep putting on that
mask keep social distancing you know
keep your activities long till we find
out for sure with all the [__] that's
been going on there could be a mass
community whatever the [__] you know or
you smart people know but just keep
yourself on the watchful on eirick
I want to thank you again brother for
being my friend always make a move how
much we laugh we I didn't say this is
what it is we have we have a girl [__]
and this is why I said you know what I'm
sick and tired of interviews I'm sick
and tired of talking with people in
tickets again kind of tiptoeing around
things for the last two weeks you know I
didn't want to come on here and repeat
what the news is saying I just want to
have a good time with you people so
likely Wednesday will be back for
[__] Bruce Lee but real quick before
we wrap it up don't forget what I told
you man I went through a rollercoaster
with you guys on this one you guys it's
emailing me thanking me and Lee for
being here during this time I want to
thank you guys for being on that end
because if you guys listen to my podcast
in the 15th you told my podcast today
you listen to the differences in my
voice you can hear the fear in my voice
you guys suit that so I owe you you owe
me okay so thank you very much for
supporting us during this difficult time
and we always got your back I want to
thank Eric Roach in the crazy gay world
and Eric Rocha I want to thank the
[__] [__] Lisa at but most of
all I want to thank you guys for being
family I love you [__] wave the
gay [__] leg I just oh my god if I
was Gabby slinging dick with this should
be like gang signs for me and I'm saying
this means fisting this means half moon
this means [__] I got [__] hang
signals for y'all see on the corner my
pop is on fire my ass is on fire I love
you guys Wednesday morning 6:00 a.m.
I'll see you then thank you again i
grouchy let me kick this [__] mule
lee-sia
[Music]